[Music]
immigration levels the United States
continued to reach new highs a new
report by the Center for Immigration
Studies estimates that the current
immigrant population in America legal
and illegal now numbers about forty four
and a half million that adds up to
almost fourteen percent of the entire
country as the highest percentage since
1910 in other words the highest
percentage that any living American has
ever seen one in seven US residents was
born in a foreign country
well polls show consistently that
Americans are not for this most when
asked want less immigration than we
currently have a century ago the last
time immigration levels were this high
the public felt the same way the public
always feels that way in every country
that has mass immigration at these
levels since we had a strong democracy
at the time the public got its wish
immigration levels were slashed
dramatically and they stayed low for
about half a century but America
unfortunately isn't nearly democracy it
once was so we can't count on the same
thing happening this time in fact
something very different is happening
economic and cultural elites demand more
and more immigration regardless of what
the public says it wants just this week
in Oregon for one example the CEO of
Nike mark Parker announced that his
company is opposing a proposal to
eliminate Oregon's sanctuary city law if
illegal immigrants don't have a right to
settle in Oregon in total defiance of
existing US law Parker says the state
will not be able to attract quote
diverse talent Parker knows what's going
on he's a businessman as long as you
fight to drive down wages in the United
States and sponsor athletes who protest
the flag the left will give you a pass
for running sweatshops overseas which it
does the public wants this immigration
law is enforced it said so clearly they
elected Donald Trump to do exactly that
but the stranglehold of our elites a
small percentage of our population is so
strong that the opposite has happened
since Trump's election America is closer
to having open borders now than ever
consider this from October 2016 through
September of 2017 more than 94 thousand
people were caught crossing the
us-mexico border
claim to be part of a family unit coming
from Guatemala El Salvador Honduras now
you'd think that illegally entering the
United States would be an automatic
ticket home and quickly but she'd be
wrong these people were not sent home
they were allowed to settle in the
United States while their cases were
resolved which in practical terms means
forever of those 94 thousand illegal
border crossers only 1500 have been sent
back in other words 98% are still here
during the same period 31,000
unaccompanied minors were detained at
the border and again 98% of them are
still here which means that America
effectively no matter what they're
telling you has no borders this is not a
secret word has got out to the rest of
the world and hundreds of thousands of
people are taking advantage of this this
is a crisis it's one created by years of
deliberate neglect by those in power
instead of acknowledging it though the
left denies there is a crisis and then
works to exacerbate the crisis virtually
everyone on the left now opposes a wall
on the grounds that it would be too
effective many opposed any sort of
border enforcement to the New York City
Council just endorsed abolishing ice on
the grounds that too many people get
deported when in fact as you just heard
almost nobody gets deported it's a lie
it makes you think maybe there's another
agenda here one has that has nothing to
do with what voters want enrique
estivate it was an anchor at Univision
and a frequent guest on the show he
joins the San Rico thanks very much for
coming on thanks for having me Chuck
so when I was born in this country the
percentage of people living here who
were foreign-born was under 5% it's now
about 14% so that's a three-fold
increase that's a huge change a huge
change in less than 50 years is the
country better or worse for that would
you say I think the country is better
and the economy is better but still
those levels 14% is actually lower than
what we had 6070 years ago even before
that where it was I'm sorry you're
allowed to your opinions not to your
effects that that's untrue and as I just
said in the open that is the first of
all the largest total number in American
history 14% number
no no the aggregate number the actual
number the millions of foreign-born in
this country is the biggest number ever
but the percentage of population is the
highest since 1910 so that's what you
know 108 years so okay so you think the
country is better for more than tripling
the percentage of foreign-born in its
borders what would be the limit how
could we get to the best possible
country
what's the idea what percentage of
Americans do you think should be
foreign-born
so this is a thing two thirds of the GDP
expansion since 2011 came from
immigrants and this is not me saying and
it's Citigroup not exactly a bastion of
open borders or socialism is an advocate
for open borders just for the record
just just so you know but okay so so
economic growth comes directly from
low-wage emigration that's your
contention that none I think you know
what we're seeing in terms of innovation
in terms of economic growth in the
country not only in sectors like
agriculture or construction or the
service sector we're seeing this too in
places like Silicon Valley in places
where innovation and technology are
driving the economy and immigrants are
becoming a key factor an engine of
growth in in those places so I agree
with you though that there is a crisis
so part of what you said is true that's
absolutely right a lot of immigrants
have been very successful and innovative
and impressive I think and great people
by the way good and a lot of them are in
Silicon Valley but the overwhelming
majority of the people we let in have
very limited skills in very low
education level and no money they're the
poor of the world that's the
overwhelming majority the people we let
in why not decide that we want to let in
every software engineer around the world
or every physician or every physicist
what why in a post-industrial country
we're letting in majority people with
low skills well because like we've said
in the past that we've discussed in the
past help is wanted in this country
these jobs are being offered to these
people so that's why they're coming to -
to the US you can build the wall a
beautiful big wall throughout that 2,000
mile war border and then a hundred feet
after that wall you'll have a big sign
that says he'll want it so people are
going to still come and try to
right you're making you're making the
case for a big business again that they
shouldn't have to pay American level
wages you and he's hiring these people
and then the herbs exploited there
weren't right no your flacking for
corporate America I get it
but let me just get right back to my
original question which was if 14%
foreign-born is good what's the limit so
if we were 90 percent foreign-born there
were much smaller percentage of
Americans living here would it be even
better so you said in the past that
you're against undocumented immigration
but also for limiting legal immigration
and I think that's that's a real issue
here I don't think we should be
addressing undocumented immigration from
a border enforcement standpoint only
from a border enforcement standpoint no
of course not and you know if you just
said that we have a crisis right now and
the policies the current policies even
the Trump administration policies are
not working that's why we should be
working on the push factors on the root
causes of immigration but on the other
hand you say you want to limit legal
immigration so that's the thing you
don't want people to come here and
request asylum legally you don't want
them to come here and internal actually
what I also so you're telling me what I
want let me tell you what I want because
I'm here I want a democracy where the
majority of voters get to decide what
their country does the big policies come
from what people who live here want in
every poll of immigration shows
Americans think the numbers are too high
but a small number of activists like you
who appearantly have all the power are
saying we don't care what you want this
is what you're getting that's not
democracy is it that's that's a kind of
government familiar in Latin America
we're an oligarchy is in control well
what am I missing here well first of all
I know exactly what polls you're
referring to because all the polls that
I've seen actually have the majority of
Americans in favor of comprehensive
immigration reform against the wall
against massive deportation against
finally separation aggression - okay but
shouldn't they be in charge look very
simple and with this if the majority of
Americans think that our immigration
levels are too high and the polls show
they do think that
then shouldn't we reduce those levels so
why don't we follow the lead of the what
percentage would you say would be
acceptable four for you and four was
fine it was was it nice it was a better
country than it is now in a lot of ways
think so just about immigration wasn't a
better country what metric it was a more
cohesive it was a less diverse and
middle-class no it's not about race
actually the middle class was vibrant
when I was born it's dying now and
that's the difference it's not about
race don't make it that way anyway we're
out of time
great to see you good to talk her bye